professor on how would someone show the
tricking of a crime scene the coming in
with false evidence to confuse
investigators that's an interesting take
there's it's only evidence until
determined that this is not pertinent to
the investigation and one thing that we
need to discuss that that we haven't
talked about yet is as a criminalist you
collect and you collect and identify and
preserve and all that stuff but then you
pass it on to the detectives you don't
go i'd say i won't i won't name names
but there's a certain show where they
had police powers and they were doing
crime scene investigations and they were
collecting evidence and yet they were
telling the perps that you're busted
because i found this that and the other
that's not real life criminalists
collect they don't carry guns maybe they
do in some jurisdictions I can't swear
to that one but they don't carry guns
they don't carry a badge well maybe a
badge to get on site that says crime
scene investigator but there they don't
have police powers as the word I'm
getting too even with the FBI and and
sheriffs and all that stuff there the
criminalist will take take and package
their goods and pass it on as i said to
the lab and then the lab will do its
research and probably kick out most of
this is pertinent or germane to our our
chest or not or ? therefore preserve it
anyway if that makes sense so then they
will pass that on to the investigator
and that's the one thing that we haven't
talked about we're talking about in
forensic science all a lot here which is
what I do but it's the police that
ultimately do everything when I say
police say please I mean you know
sheriff or CHP or you know I no
derogatory towards anybody just police
policing so the detectives the police
officers will do the actual
investigation and the in hit the beat
and do the the backup information
if you find a fingerprint they have to
find the hand that matches it they have
to do that by going out into the field
and interviewing people and talking to
people and collecting fingerprints and
matching them but you have to have a
warrant to do that I mean there's a
whole male you of police procedural and
there's a great books on that by even
the writers store there's one thanks
golf release police procedure or
procedural one of the two I recommend
anybody that wants to do any of this
though to read a lot particularly if
you're a writer if you're an actor as we
discussed before you're going to do what
the director in the script tell you this
comes down to writing read up as much as
you can as best as you can there's
plenty of website to put a course like
Wikipedia as we say in education you
can't cite Wikipedia no offense you
can't cite Wikipedia because it's not
peer-reviewed so you want things that
are by crc press taylor Francis SL
elsevier those are some of the the the
the morn own forensic book publishers I
would look into those I would look into
websites Zeno's forensics page was
fantastic I don't know if it exists or
not anymore but that one list everything
schools and places to learn stuff take
classes don't be afraid to take a
professional class go to the California
Institute up in Sacramento and take a
fingerprinting class they have a whole
degree program in santa ana college here
in Los Angeles are actually orange
county has a a policing program
sometimes you can get into post training
police officer standards training so
even if you can't get into them maybe
you can get their materials study
you